it's now the beginning of October 2015
so it's time for me to shoot another
monthly update video in which I tell my
viewers and subscribers about some of
the key things that went on in September
and about what we've got coming up in
October now this is a particularly
momentous time as I'll tell you in just
a moment this is probably the very last
of these update videos that I'll be
shooting from New York at least for the
foreseeable future because as you know
we're moving so let me launch right into
the big three things that I want to tell
you that first and then i'll tell you
about September and then about the rest
of October so of course the biggest
thing is we are moving cross-country
about the midpoint of of October we get
our big moving truck on the 13th or so
then start loading it up with all the
all the effects of our life and in
essence and then we travel cross-country
to Milwaukee Wisconsin where we are
going to be living from from this point
on at least for the time being my wife
and I are both originally from Wisconsin
were actually both from the Greater
Milwaukee area I grew up west of
Waukesha she grew up east of Waukesha so
I was growing up in the country she was
growing up in the Milwaukee suburbs that
were still a little green space at the
time and so we're really looking forward
to this move it's going to open up some
great opportunities for us it's going to
place us closer to our old friends and
even more importantly to our families
who for the most part live out in that
area so that is a one really big thing
coming up another thing I would like to
put on your radar is that if you haven't
been following the half-hour hagel video
series up to this point you probably
want to start getting into it now in
part because we're now tackling some of
the most famous portions of the
phenomenology the master-slave dialectic
and much of October will in fact be
exploring that dialectic so if you're if
you have any interest in Hagel German
ideal
ism philosophy dialectics any of that
sort of stuff you probably want to at
least tune in for those videos the third
thing is that we are getting ready this
month for something that's happening
next month at the beginning of next
month and then for us running the rest
of the month and that is stoic Week 2015
stoic week is now scheduled for the
first week of November it used to be
scheduled for the last week of November
and it was started by these people
involved with the modern stoicism
movement and the University of Exeter
they created a blog they created a
course they created a handbook they
created all sorts of really cool stuff
and they offer this free to the general
public they also coordinate events and
they publicize and coordinate with
people who are offering events at other
places and I will indeed be offering
some stoic week events but i'll tell you
more about that come November in any
case what I'm doing is I'm getting ready
for the launch of stoic week where I'll
have a series of videos coming out and
I'm also going to be releasing a open
access class that I'll tell you more
about in the October section what went
on in the month of September so
September was a pretty busy month as
they always turn out to be for us I had
three events uh one of which was
entirely online one of which was you
might say out there in the ether and one
of which was an on-site face-to-face
event so the first one was the final
understanding anger series lecture which
was on Thomas Aquinas hosted by the
Kingston public library that brought
that series to a close and then
afterwards we went out to lunch and I
you know said my goodbyes to everyone
they were a little bit sad that that I
was leaving the area but you know it's
been a really great discussion group and
that brings to a close a nine video 9
session series on anger in
ancient and medieval literature
philosophy religious writings it was
really a great thing to do so that was a
great event I did a theology matters
radio show guest appearance this time
talking about my book on the Christian
philosophy debates of the 1930s and some
of the key issues who was involved why
their debates in the first place I'll
put a link to that so you can access it
if you want to have got you know sound
recording of it and I did another half
hour Hagel public question-and-answer
session my once I past a certain level
of support from my Patriot backers I
committed to offering these google
hangouts where anybody can come and ask
questions or engage in discussion about
Hegel's phenomenology or broader topics
so those are the three events for
September I also committed to and
managed to pull off doing more blogging
and getting my blogs a bit more tidied
up you know fixing layouts improving the
view ability as they call it of the
blogs so I did some writing in my main
blog or exes do you know NTK I also did
quite a bit of blogging in the half-hour
Hagel blog I wrote one entry in the
heavy metal philosopher blonde which is
good because that's my side project and
then I also resuscitated the virtue
ethics digest blog which has been just
sitting out there doing nothing other
than you know garnering views from
people who are looking at it saying I
wonder when this guy is going to write
something again well I finally did get
to write something this month I also
been doing a lot of work on academic
writing you know tidying up some some
proposals that I have to send out also
working on two papers that I'm going to
be presenting this month that I'll tell
you about in the October section so what
else I started teaching three classes
online now all of my teaching is is
online which is very convenient since
I'm moving I'm teaching two sections of
world views and values
which is a more or less like an intro to
philosophy class I tend to focus a lot
on social theory and social and
political philosophy in it those are for
Maris College and I have a whole crop of
students in both of those sections it
was such a popular class they had to
open up two sections i also am teaching
a global Center for Advanced Studies
philosophical foundations class that's
that class that I developed that that
gets people sort of a good map or lay of
the land of you know the main areas in
philosophy what some of the key issues
are and what some of the key thinkers on
those issues would be that one will run
all the way through December I did quite
a bit of video work I released six half
hour hagel videos that took us through
the end of the first section of
self-consciousness and into the
master-slave dialectic or lordship and
bondage we didn't actually get this
month up to the point where hagel
mentions Lord and and bondsman or master
and slave because it takes them about
halfway through that section to
introduce that but but the dialectics
have been quite quite important I've
continued releasing videos on Plato's
symposium the course that I taught
earlier this summer in August created a
lot of core concept videos on the
symposium and I've been gradually
putting those into the public domain I
still have some that I need to do that
with and of course the understanding
anger a video I released that brings
that series to a close which is kind of
cool to to be able to say and I did a
video that was rather new for me
something that I've never done an
unboxing video it's unlike many unboxing
videos and then I spent a lot more time
more or less ruminating about why the
objects were important to be it was
about a banjo case a new banjo cases
I've got and so I talked about the old
banjo case and the banjo and why it's
meaningful to me has it has to do with
my my you know father and his original
purchase of the band
him play than my taking it up after he
died and continuing to play it to the
present I did not unfortunately get the
law of the promised what would I call it
current events video done I just haven't
had a time given all that I've been
doing getting ready for the move I also
didn't produce any more critical
thinking videos and I think those are
going to be on hold for a little while
until everything is is set up in
Milwaukee so what did what did I spend
my time doing a lot of putting things
into boxes you notice the bookshelves
are completely bare except for the few
books that I tell myself that I need I
probably don't actually need to have all
these here but you know what it's like
being a bibliophile you never want to be
without your books and it was a
traumatic experience to have to well two
things you have to take all those books
and take them off the shelves and say
I'm not going to have access to this for
a while and then I had to load all those
into my my my out back and drive them
into the storage area which is kind of
like our staging zone for the move
because our apartment here is too small
they have a lot of boxes piled up
everywhere so we rented a storage area
and I am moved something like 90 bankers
boxes of books and books into their a
whole bunch of other things a number of
bigger boxes that that you know sort of
I would say like 3-foot by 3-foot by
3-foot cubes full of stuff so
practically our whole life is there I've
even like we took a lot of things to
donations at the buddhist center of the
road so it has been a major divestment
at least as far as the apartment is
concerned of all the accoutrements of
our life and it was good for me in part
because i got a lot of working out ton
through that I'm not somebody inclined
to exercise much and I certainly got a
lot of exercise so that was a month of
September let's talk now about October
what's coming up during this this month
I have a three
events two of which are actually
connected with the same conference but
they're on different days so i'm going
to call them two separate events and one
which is an online of that towards the
end of the month on october nine i am
going to be giving a paper in the
Gabrielle Marcel society satellite
session of the American Catholic
philosophical association being hosted
in boston massachusetts on october 10th
i will be giving another paper one on
Kierkegaard and his philosophical
fragments in the international 80 and
Jill soul society and so we've got both
of those going on it's it's going to be
a great conference I might do some video
work actually about the conference or
even possibly some interviews with
people that I know who might be up for
that sort of stuff staying in a pretty
swank hotel downtown the ACPA tends to
have a history of having you stay at
pretty upscale places and so I want to
make the most particularly that I can in
doing a lot of networking but I'm going
to be giving those those two papers so
if you're in boston and you you want to
see me talk you can come to these these
sessions I don't think that anyone would
would keep you up towards the end of the
month october twenty eighth i will do
another half hour Hagel public question
and answer and discussion google hangout
i'll be offering it thanks to the
generosity of my patriot donors so those
are the events not an awful lot going on
as far as events this month but that's
in part because the biggest event is not
a public one it's not involving me
talking it's my wife and I and our you
no pets moving cross-country from the
Hudson Valley of New York where I'm
shooting right now all the way to
milwaukee wisconsin it's it's a return
home like I said for us since we're
originally from the area so it's going
to open up a lot of opportunities and I
would like to at this point
say if you are somebody who's wanted to
connect with me in the past and you live
in the Milwaukee or Chicago area or even
the Midwest in general send me an email
gregan reason I oh and I'm going to be
looking for speaking opportunities and
opportunities to partner with
organizations to do the sort of work and
bringing philosophy and to practice that
reason I oh does that that's our company
so you know by all means do that I also
would suggest if you're interested in
getting out our mailing list send me an
email as well I'm still teaching my
classes this month the two the two
sections of the mayor's world views and
values and the one philosophical
foundations class but I'm also like I
said getting ready for stoic week so
here's where I'm going to tell you about
what we've got coming up it's really
quite cool stoic week itself is a really
great event and I strongly suggest
getting involved with it even if you're
not a stoic I'm not myself a stoic I'm
more of an Aristotelian there's also the
whole conversation there that could be
had but stoicism is a you know a great
ancient school of philosophy there are a
lot of modern proponents of it and it's
being sort of rethought and relived in
the contemporary setting so you know I
would suggest getting involved with that
they will offer a free 7-day stoic you
know mindfulness meditation sort of sort
of class that you can get in on this
time it's going to focus on Marcus
Aurelius as meditation so really quite
quite cool stuff I'm going to be in the
class there's a lot of other major
philosophers who will also likely be in
the class people who have an interest in
stoicism now after that well I'm also
going to have a stoic week event in
November but I'll tell you about that in
the November video but after that I am
going to have a four-week entirely
online open access course offered
through the g KS and it will be free
is going to be on stoicism specifically
on epictetus is enchiridion that is
uncreated specifically on epictetus 'as
discourses i will talk about the
enchiridion but that's you know not that
that big of it here the here's the
discourses now of course this gives you
a little bit of a overstatement visually
about how big this text is because this
is a lobe edition with the Greek on one
side and the English on the other so you
know half so the discourses would be a
volume about this size readable during a
month and that is what the enchiridion
was excerpted from so we will talk about
the enchiridion but we're to mainly
focus on the discourses it is going to
be a really cool class if any of you any
of you have taken classes with me before
you know I provide students with a ton
of resources I shoot videos you know I
hold discussion sessions so that's what
i'll be building this month to get it
ready for next month that leads me to
videos so half hour Hagel I'm on track
to produce another six half hour Hagel
videos this month I think we will
probably finish up with the master-slave
dialectic and move into stoicism
skepticism and the unhappy consciousness
which is great because that means that
we'll be doing that during the time that
stoic week is going on I still have
quite a few Plato's symposium videos to
release and so you can expect to see
those this month i do want to try to
shoot a current of that video this month
we'll see how that goes I can't make
great promises given the move and all
the uncertainty that comes up with that
but I will also be shooting a lot of
videos on Epictetus a--'s and Korea
again on epictetus is discourses I may
as well shoot some on the enchiridion
too but I will be shooting videos on the
discourses precisely for that course and
I will be shooting a sequence of videos
for stoic week that i'll be releasing in
november during stoic but if I have
and I get all the symposium stuff
released I will probably start releasing
some of the Epictetus discourses core
concept videos ahead of time just to
give you a little teaser about what's
coming up I still have the same and some
footage that I need to assemble edit and
release as a interview video I've been
sitting on that for about what three
months now four hooks now I need to get
that out so that that may have to wait
until we finish the move however that's
everything that's going on in October so
pretty busy month pretty momentous I'm
really looking forward to this move I am
most looking forward to having moved
Tammy actually engaging in the move
because I'm not looking forward to two
days of law and driving where my wife is
in the in our car and I'm driving the
big truck on my own not entirely on my
own but you know by myself and then you
know stopping off halfway and I'm not
looking forward to hoofing boxes let's
and stuff I am really looking forward to
being in a cool apartment in Milwaukee
and getting to see old friends and
family any time that I want to and
having the internet setup and and you
know a nice kitchen and and things like
that but that that is going to wait
again like I said earlier out of the
video if you're in the Milwaukee area
the Greater Milwaukee area so that would
also include the fox cities in Wisconsin
that you know all extended as far as
Madison if you're in the chicagoland
area and you want to connect up with my
best way to do that is to email me at
Greg at reason I oh if you're interested
in having me come and give a talk at a
school at a library church you know I
knew all sorts of venues if you got
events that you want to organize if
you're interested in hosting my
providing a workshop I'm game for all
that sort of stuff so reach out and
contact me and we'll talk about it
otherwise have a great month of October
I hope to see some of you at these these
events at least the online event and if
I don't I'll see you on me the flip side
of the move